you probably heard these stormy Daniels
book is out you know that yeah this guy
has a copy there we go let's not read it
now stormy Daniels has written a memoir
and in it she describes sex with
President Trump as quote the least
impressive sex she's ever had yeah once
she heard this Melania Trump said that
confirms it he did sleep with her only
she would know that this gets disturbing
if you brought children please take them
out now who would bring children I don't
know yeah I think your kid should be
taken away from me you bring him if you
brought children your children I'll be
taken away from you now in her new
memoir stormy Daniels described
president Trump's penis as being like
the mushroom character in Super Mario
Brothers yes that's what she said yeah
in other words stormy Daniels is every
man's fantasy a porn star who plays
video games that is actually something
we can get behind
by the world yeah that's it I just
wished that's one of those things that
just I'd bum me out to read you well you
know we didn't get to use to know what
our presidents penises look like it's a
really a golden age for us that's
something not just kind of what it looks
like exactly what it looks like yeah
yeah and and and it's it's haunting me
frankly yeah well don't think about it
now all right what do you think about
now Trump's penis all right you were
thinking about that it's red and white
spotter I know
[Applause]
hey and that department I'm not one to
criticize
it's natural freckling okay this show is
we should just stop now we should maybe
just stop now thank you for being here
you'll all get a toaster oven on the way
out I don't think they even make toasts
anymore they do well covering the Emmys
let you'd watch the Emmys that's enough
for me too allowed to go on well
covering the Emmys last night the New
York Times as you hear this the New York
Times confused actress Angela Bassett
with former White House advisor
Omarosa yeah making matters worse today
The Times extended a heartfelt apology
to Serena Williams I thought that was
going in the wrong direction hard to get
you folks back after Trump's penis isn't
it we'll get you back this is just these
next few jokes are just therapeutic
afterwards okay hey here we go
[Music]
what are you thinking about now Andy I'm
just I'm just gonna I'm not gonna say
okay a Sesame Street writer claims that
Bert and Ernie are gay but here's the
weird thing
not for each other that's the weird part
oh they were just genuinely just for no
real they didn't it's just they were
just bummed out yeah yeah but it's not
for each other what can't they love
other people know what's wrong with you
I can't Ernie like snuffleupagus that's
too bad
they've been together for 40 years it's
like they're trapped in the loveless
marriage that's what you said you're
bummed out we came out here and this
crowd was super happy they are so bummed
right now No we'll just rip really trust
me folks the show's gonna get a lot
better in about 20 minutes by the way
this is the news this isn't us yes it's
just what's in the headline I know what
you guys were gonna like that's not me
asking
that's me telling we paid you folks good
money they're looking at each other we
didn't get paid
a new lawsuit came out it claims that
female employees were harassed at Del
Taco restaurants yeah yeah the lawsuit
says the women were exposed to unwanted
advances crude remarks and food from Del
Taco
[Applause]
didn't dig me out of the hole but this
one will folks for this one I'm gonna do
something I haven't done I think ever
I'm gonna explain something before I do
the joke for this next joke
all I need you to know is that in the
1990s and some of you will remember this
there was a false crazy rumor that
Richard Gere put gerbils in his butt for
sexual pleasure anyone heard of that
rumour before okay there we go right I
need you all to remember that and know
that when I tell this next joke you with
me
hey did you hear this lesson gentlemen
Richard Gere's wife is having a baby
yeah yeah yeah when his pregnant wife
said it's so exciting having a little
tiny life inside you Gere said I know
I just thank you thank you
thank you I just got to make believe
Oscar for that joke okay okay an Oscar
all right
I don't know just let it go I'm all
right I'm all right get a Nobel Peace
Prize yeah whatever
you